for more on the Russia investigation we
turn to Jonathan Allen columnist for
roll call John good morning good morning
it seems like this meeting story just
won't settle will it I mean we still
they're still we still not entirely sure
who was there right the list of
attendees is growing with each passing
minute obviously it wasn't 40 or 50
people but it was not two or three
people so we're up to six seven eight
people it's not going away for a couple
of reasons number one it really is the
sort of smoking gun connecting the
allegations of collusion to an actual
exhibit of something that looks like
collusion and then number two because
Donald Trump jr.
went out and said that he'd kind of
shown everybody everything and it turned
out that wasn't the case and then the
president praised his transparency which
was not entirely transparent as it turns
out it turns out that he was it was more
being transparencies kind of a
double-sided word there like it was
transparent that he was lying pretty
quickly it's sort of has raised
questions of credibility for the White
House but also for the Republican Party
trying to move forward legislation right
now it's got to be a huge frustration
for them as well it is a frustration for
them I actually think these are two
separate issues where you don't think
there's an impact I don't think I don't
I think the reason the Republicans are
struggling with the health care
legislation in particular is that it's a
bill that's tremendously unpopular in
the public I'm if you look at the
approval ratings on that that's the key
issue and I think it's convenient to
sometimes blame what's going on with the
White House on other issues particularly
with Russia as a reason that the health
care bill isn't moving forward but I
think Republicans actually need right
now to pass something more than they
otherwise would because of what's going
on with the Russia scandal so if
anything I think it offers well for
those who are trying to collect those
boats and it's difficult at this point
for the Republicans to move on to
anything else before they deal with
health care correct that's right they
promised to do this for seven plus years
now to repeal and replace Obamacare
first it was repealed that was repealed
and replaced and a lot of them most of
them feel like they can't go home to
their constituents and say we didn't get
this done what is the reality because
right now we already have two
Republicans who have said they will not
vote for it so you sit at that 50 which
is the only threshold that they have how
realistic is that we'll see it passed
well so you've got this test boat coming
up this week where they need to get 50
including vice-president Mike Pence if
they get the 50 we're on that threshold
right now there are still a lot of
Republican senators who haven't said
that they're gonna vote to to proceed so
I think right now it's still up in the
air and then of course even if they get
that motion to proceed that doesn't
necessarily mean that they'll be able to
pass the bill nor does it mean that
they'll be able to reconcile that bill
with the House bill and actually send
something to President Ron I haven't
scored this yet right we haven't seen
the CBO's the Congressional Budget
Office is an estimate of exactly what
this bill would do because there have
been so many changes yeah and how
critical do you think that is to its
potential passage I think it's important
I think that without it it makes it a
lot harder for senators who were
undecided to sort of take a leap of
faith if they know what the numbers are
then they can try to frame how they're
gonna argue why they voted for it or why
they voted against it one of the
interesting things has been when we saw
Obamacare President Obama was there in
the forefront and able to help push that
along you haven't had president Trump
able to do that in this case that's
right I think that may be a preference
of the congressional leaders that it
would not necessarily be helpful for
them especially in the Senate right now
for President Trump to be on Capitol
Hill really pushing this bill I think
the argument that in order to get this
done you've got to have Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell making the
argument to these senators that they are
better off passing this even if it's
unpopular than doing nothing
John Allen thank you very much we
appreciate the insight thank you dinner